Bonjour tout le monde
et bienvenue dans ce nouveau podcast
aujourd'hui j'avais envie de parler
d'un sujet qui est intéressant et qui est important
pour l'apprentissage des langues
c'est la mémoire
donc je me suis pris
quelques notes sur mon portable
donc si je regarde mon portable
c'est parce que je regarde mes notes
mais du coup aujourd'hui
j'avais envie de
discuter de comment booster sa mémoire
comment améliorer sa mémoire
notamment pour l'apprentissage des langues
je voulais commencer avec un disclaimer
la mémoire c'est comme un muscle
le cerveau c'est comme un muscle
si vous n'entraînez pas votre mémoire
si vous ne vous entraînez pas à mémoriser
vous n'allez pas progresser
ça demande de l'exercice
comme quand on va à la salle de sport faire des ...
soulever des poids
faire de la musculation
si vous ne travaillez pas vos biceps
vos triceps enfin vos bras
vous n'allez pas progresser
et c'est pareil avec la mémoire
donc quand on voit ce genre de vidéo sur YouTube
on peut être vite tenté de croire que
juste parce qu'on regarde la vidéo
on va améliorer notre mémoire tout de suite après
il n'y a pas de technique miracle il y a des techniques
mais elle nécessite de l'entraînement
donc une fois que vous avez regardé cette vidéo
ne vous attendez pas à tout mémoriser très facilement
mais posez-vous la question de plutôt
comment installer une routine
pour entraîner ma mémoire pour m'entraîner à mémoriser
de nouvelles choses
et notamment dans l'apprentissage des langues
la mémoire c'est
primordial puisque
il faut apprendre des centaines
des milliers de mots de vocabulaire
c'est même très central parce que le vocabulaire
c'est ce qui permet
de s'exprimer et c'est ce qui permet
de parler et de comprendre
dans la langue que l'on apprend
et parfois il est même enfin même tout le temps
il est plus important d'avoir du vocabulaire
que d'avoir une grammaire parfaite
si vous avez une grammaire qui n'est pas parfaite
mais vous utilisez le bon vocabulaire
les personnes vous comprendront
et l'inverse ne fonctionne pas
si vous avez une grammaire parfaite pardon
mais que vous n'utilisez pas le bon vocabulaire
ça ne marchera pas donc
la mémoire c'est hyper important
pour apprendre du vocabulaire
le premier paramètre qui favorise la mémoire
c'est la répétition
je sais pas si c'est juste en France
mais quand on est petit
on apprend souvent des poésies à l'école
et ensuite il faut passer devant la classe les réciter
vers par vers
ligne par ligne
et du coup quand on apprend ce genre de poésie
c'est un texte assez long
et il y a pas trente-six-mille solutions
on se met devant le texte et on répète
on répète on répète
au début on connaît la première partie
puis on commence à répéter la deuxième
puis on commence à répéter la première et la deuxième ensemble
et cette répétition
c'est comme ça qu'on apprend qu'on mémorise
le poème qu'on va devoir réciter devant la classe
et ça j'en ai beaucoup parlé
et c'est quelque chose de très populaire
mais pour ce qui s'agit de
pour ce qui est de la répétition
il y a les systèmes SRS
spaced repetition système
c'est des systèmes qui vont faire répéter
des cartes de mémoire de mémorisation
pour faciliter
leur apprentissage
leur mémorisation
et en fait
il y a des logiciels très populaires comme Anki
et en fait je pense que ce genre de logiciel
ça représente la mémoire un peu comme un mille-feuille
c'est une pâtisserie française
1000 feuilles c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 1000 feuilles
il y a 1000 étages
et en fait la mémoire ça fonctionne un peu pareil
c'est-à-dire que tout en haut
il y a une mémoire très court terme
et tout en bas il y a la mémoire long terme
le but du SRS ça va essayer de
avec la répétition
de faire en sorte que ce que vous apprenez
descend dans les étages
va de plus en plus vers la mémoire long terme
un exemple très concret c'est de la mémoire court terme
par exemple
c'est quand vous êtes sur le quai d'une gare
quand vous allez prendre un train
parfois vous sortez votre billet vous regardez
ah je suis dans le wagon 16
place 86
vous remettez le ticket
dans votre poche
et vous avez déjà oublié votre place
ça c'est de la mémoire très court terme
c'est-à-dire que
à peine vous mémorisez
quelques secondes plus tard c'est déjà parti
et à l'inverse
la mémoire très long terme c'est par exemple
peut-être que vous vous rappelez d'un jingle de pub
de votre enfance
c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui passait
à la télé quand vous étiez enfant
et ça se trouve vous vous rappelez même
vous vous rappelez très bien de la musique
de ce jingle de pub
une des raisons pour laquelle c'est une mémoire long terme
c'est sûrement que cette pub
revenait régulièrement à la télé
tous les jours vous voyiez cette pub
et du coup la musique
vous avez mémorisé la musique assez facilement
mais du coup voilà
il y a deux extrêmes
entre une mémoire très court terme et une mémoire
long terme bien évidemment quand on apprend une langue
on a envie de tout mémoriser à long terme
l'idée c'est que une fois qu'on a appris un mot
on le retient pour toujours entre guillemets
c'est théorique
ce n'est pas parfait
parfois on apprend des choses
on oublie
ensuite on apprend quelque chose qu'on apprend
qu'on mémorise très bien
une autre chose qu'on va oublier très facilement
ce n'est pas une science exacte
donc ne soyez pas trop dur avec vous-même
et utilisez voilà un outil de SRS
et ensuite le deuxième paramètre
c'est que la mémoire fonctionne par association
on mémorise plus facilement quelque chose
si on connaît déjà
quelque chose qui est en lien avec ce qu'on apprend
le plus évident
l'exemple le plus évident
c'est par exemple en tant que français
il est beaucoup plus facile
d'apprendre une langue comme l'espagnol
l'italien, le portugais
que d'apprendre une langue comme le japonais
tout simplement parce que les mots qu'on va apprendre
sont très ressemblants avec ceux qu'on connaît déjà
et du coup ça va
on va les mémoriser beaucoup plus facilement
quand j'ai commencé à apprendre le japonais
au début en fait
les sons sont très différents
et du coup au début
j'avais
l'impression que tous les mots se ressemblaient
que tous les mots étaient identiques
et du coup j'avais beaucoup de mal
à mémoriser ces mots puisque je n'avais aucun repère
je n'avais aucun repère
je n'avais rien que je connaissais déjà
qui se rapprochait un peu
des mots que j'essayais d'apprendre
donc c'était très difficile à mémoriser
et pour ça quand c'est comme ça
l'idée c'est d'essayer d'utiliser des techniques
pour faire en sorte de trouver quelque chose dans notre
mémoire qui existait déjà
pour que les nouveaux mots s'accrochent
pour retenir ces nouveaux mots
en créant un lien avec quelque chose qu'on connaît déjà
et ça pour ça il y a plusieurs solutions
la première, une solution
une technique
que j'ai beaucoup utilisé pour le japonais
et notamment pour les Kanji
pour les caractères chinois
c'est d'inventer une histoire
d'inventer une histoire mnémotechnique
c'est-à-dire que quand vous allez avoir un mot comme
ce mot ne vous dit rien
comme il ne ressemble à rien
que ce que vous connaissez déjà
l'idée ça va être d'essayer d'inventer une histoire
pour le raccrocher à quelque chose
et cette histoire
elle peut être complètement irrationnelle et c'est même
j'ai l'impression
plus efficace quand c'est complètement irrationnel
je vous donne un exemple
par exemple chicken
en français on va dire poulet
poulet pour un anglophone
ce n'est pas un mot qui ressemble à quelque chose
qui existe déjà
en anglais on dit chicken
en français on dit poulet
les 2 mots sont très différents
et du coup quand on essaie
d'apprendre le mot poulet
en général on l'oublie assez facilement
l'idée ici ça va être de
décomposer le mot pour inventer une histoire
qui permette
de mémoriser plus facilement le mot
j'avais donné un exemple à un élève une fois
et je vais vous le donner
attention ce genre de phrase
ça peut être très ridicule
mais ce n'est vraiment pas le sujet
plus c'est irrationnel
plus ça va être facile à mémoriser
et du coup pour poulet
j'avais essayé de lui dire
est-ce qu'on peut pas découper en poule et "ey"
et du coup ce qu'on avait
enfin ce que j'avais
essayé de créer comme histoire c'est
imagine par exemple
tu joues au billard du coup
donc au pool en anglais si je me trompe pas
et en face de toi il y a un poulet
tu joues contre un poulet
qui quand tu tapes à chaque fois
crie Hey Hey
donc en fait t'es en train de jouer au billard
et y a un poulet en face de toi
et y a un chicken en face de toi qui crie Hey
donc t'es en train de pool et lui il dit Hey
et du coup ça fait pool Hey
quand on met les deux ensemble ça fait pool Hey
dis comme ça
je sais très bien que ça paraît complètement ridicule
et que ça paraît complètement illogique
mais rien que le fait d'avoir
une histoire comme ça qui soit un peu irrationnelle
déjà on s'en souvient
parce que c'est tellement n'importe quoi
qu'on mémorise facilement cette histoire
mais ensuite on va vite associer les sons
qu'on entend et se rappeler du mot poulet
on joue au billard au pool
l'autre il crit Hey tout le temps pool-hey
et en fait en même temps on visualise
un poulet qui est devant nous
à jouer avec nous au billard
cette histoire est vraiment bizarre
mais en fait
quand vous allez inventer ce genre d'histoire
plus vous mettez de détails plus c'est irrationnel
plus ça va vous aider à mémoriser
et ensuite quand vous allez commencer à revoir
vos cartes de mémorisation
dans votre
outil SRS
au début vous allez avoir marqué poulet
et vous allez peut-être hésiter un peu et
d'un coup vous allez-vous dire ah mais oui
l'histoire du billard avec le poulet
contre qui je joue
etc et comme ça vous allez faire le cheminement
et vous allez-vous dire
oui ça veut dire chicken
les premiers jours ça va se passer comme ça
et petit à petit
en fait vous aurez de moins en moins besoin
de cette histoire pour mémoriser le mot
jusqu'au moment
où vous allez complètement oublier cette histoire
et en fait cette histoire elle va servir de
scotch pour accrocher
le mot que vous essayez de mémoriser
dans votre mémoire
j'espère que mon explication n'a pas été trop
bizarre ou trop
confuse mais voilà
je tiens vraiment à préciser
que c'est quelque chose que j'ai fait
pour le japonais
et ça a vraiment fonctionné
j'ai oublié la majeure partie des histoires
mais c'était des trucs complètement loufoques
enfin ça n'avait rien de rationnel
c'était complètement irrationnel
et plus c'est
plus c'est déjenté moins c'est rationnel
plus c'est efficace
ensuite il va y avoir
une autre technique
ça va être des phrases mnemotechniques
on va faire une phrase
et on va utiliser les premières lettres de chaque mot
pour se rappeler
d'une liste de mots
je ne l'ai jamais utilisé pour
l'apprentissage des langues
parce que je ne vois pas trop comment l'utiliser
mais je vais vous donner un exemple par exemple
si vous voulez
mémoriser toutes les planètes du système solaire
vous allez créer une phrase
et chaque première lettre des mots de cette phrase
va correspondre
à une planète
et par exemple
j'ai trouvé sur internet une phrase comme
"mon vaisseau te mènera jusque sur une nouvelle planète"
et en fait si on prend les
si on prend les
les premières lettres de chaque mot
ça nous donne
M V T M J S U N P
et du coup
et du coup ça va donner quelque chose comme Mars
Vénus Terre Mercure Jupiter
Saturne Uranus
Neptune Pluton
et normalement si je ne me suis pas trompé
j'ai donné toutes les planètes du système solaire
je me suis peut-être trompé mais en tout cas voilà
ce genre de phrase permet de
juste en retenant une phrase
on peut retenir beaucoup d'informations
et ça c'est valable pour beaucoup de listes
par exemple tous les présidents des États-Unis
de l'histoire des États-Unis
ce genre de chose
ce n'est pas vraiment appliquable
je pense à l'apprentissage des langues
mais ça reste une technique utilisable
et enfin la dernière technique c'est la spatialisation
là aussi en fait
comme pour l'histoire
on va essayer de raccrocher les mots
qu'on essaie d'apprendre à
quelque chose qu'on connaît
et ça marche bien avec la spatialisation
utiliser un espace qu'on connaît déjà
par exemple votre appartement ou votre maison
vous pouvez les yeux fermés
vous rappeler de comment est
quelle pièce, où est situé quelle pièce
la nuit sans allumer la lumière
vous pouvez aller jusqu'aux toilettes
sans trop de difficultés
et bien
ça c'est utiliser ça pour apprendre de nouveaux mots
et ça par exemple ça va essayer de
visualiser
de visualiser les mots sur les murs
dans un espace qu'on connaît déjà
c'est quelque chose qui est utilisé il me semble
par les personnes qui font des concours de mémoire
par exemple
mémoriser toutes les décimales de Pi
enfin un nombre maximal
de décimales de Pi
elles vont visualiser les choses
écrites sur un mur qu'elles connaissent
écrites dans un espace qu'elles connaissent
et ainsi, mais essayer
de faire en sorte que ces chiffres
entrent plus facilement dans leur mémoire
dans le cas de l'apprentissage des langues
c'est quelque chose qui peut être essayé
je ne l'ai jamais vraiment trop appliqué
mais par exemple
si vous collez des mots
dans votre "chez vous"
vous allez peut-être
à force de les voir à tel ou tel endroit
commencer à mémoriser plus facilement
j'ai essayé ça
j'ai essayé cette technique avec un élève
mais je ne sais pas si ça a été efficace
c'était par exemple
d'écrire le nom des pièces de la maison
de l'appartement en français
sur les portes
de son appartement ou de sa maison
par exemple sur la porte de la cuisine
écrire la cuisine
et ça
comme tous les jours vous vous déplacez chez vous
comme vous vous déplacez
et que vous voyez ces mots inscrits dans un lieu
que vous connaissez bien
ça permet de faciliter la mémorisation
donc voilà c'était à peu près
tout pour les techniques de mémorisation
que je voulais vous présenter
j'espère que ça vous sera utile
j'insiste sur la technique d'inventer une histoire
pour moi ça a été quelque chose d'efficace
donc si vous voulez essayer
n'hésitez pas
et aussi si vous avez des techniques
propres à vous que je n'ai pas listées ici
n'hésitez pas à les écrire dans les commentaires
et à donner vos propres retours
encore une fois
ce qui compte c'est la mise en application
vous avez beau apprendre
une technique si vous ne vous entraînez pas à l'utiliser
ça ne sera jamais efficace
donc essayez régulièrement pendant une certaine période
et ensuite vous voyez
ce qui est efficace pour vous ou ce qui ne l'est pas
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que cette vidéo
que cette vidéo pardon vous sera utile
et voilà n'hésitez pas à donner vos retours
et je vous dis à la prochaine